on n'a jamais eu 32 réacteurs en
maintenance plus des problèmes
d'approvisionnement du gaz donc c'est
une situation inédite catastrophique
inédite elle est grave et donc il faut
se mobiliser et pourquoi le gars ça pose
un problème parce que le bias et pas
simplement pour consommer du gaz c'est
aussi pour produire de l'électricité
donc si vous importez de l'électricité à
un pays qui l'a produit à partir du gaz
et qu'il ya moins de gaz il ya des
tensions sur le marché de l'électricité
aussi voyez ce que je veux dire non le
gaz est utilisé aussi pour produire de
l'électricité vous quand il ya des
tensions sur le gaz ça pèse sur la
production d'électricité parce que là
c'est plus clair et les secourir les gas
gas à ses progrès sur tous nos matches
en europe il ya des importations
exportations d'électricité mais il ya
des centrales électriques en europe se
produisent à partir du gaz sah auxiette
il ya des tensions sur le gaz russe ou
sur le marché du gaz ça peut rendre
difficile la production d'électricité
aussi donc le gaz peut poser un problème
en termes de production d'électricité et
donc contribuer au black out aussi
indirectement alors justement non les
français qui nous regardent il est 21h
on est on est en direct on se pose cette
question
aura-t-on de l'électricité cet hiver on
voit de plus en plus de choses qu'on
n'avait jamais vu avant se produire là
il ya une piscine qui vient d'être fermé
on nous demande de faire des efforts
c'est de baisser de 10% je suis pas du
tout ce que ça correspond à quoi ça
correspond disposant mais le chiffre que
vous avez donnée lorsqu'on était en
confinement le ca a baissé de 8,2 bon
sens vous avez dit donc c'est alors
qu'on ne sait rien ça ça fait flipper la
ja raphaël beau roman qui nous dit qu'on
n'a jamais eu une situation aussi
catastrophique avec une trentaine voilà
deux nous avait dit de ce2 alors de
réacteurs à l'endurance mais certains
vont repartir avant l'hiver quand même
il ya cet espoir cet espoir donc là
aujourd'hui on est le 6 septembre est ce
qu'à votre avis vous qui êtes un
économiste sérieux est-ce que vous
pensez que cet hiver là c'est à dire à
horizon novembre décembre vous même pour
les fêtes de noël est ce que vous pensez
qu'il va y avoir de grosses restrictions
est ce que vous pensez que tous les
foyers français pourront avoir de
l'électricité ou est-ce que ça va pas
augmenter oui ça augmente et oui
justement mais le truc c'est que à un
moment où les gens pourront plus payer
obama il ya deux questions différentes
alors lié à la question alors en faisant
de la pénurie
première question a priori il y aura pas
de black de pénurie d'électricité pour
les ménages mais quand on peut y avoir
ce qu'on appelle du délestage
c'est-à-dire des coupures localisées
temporaires et exceptionnelles pour des
sites industriels d'accord soit assez
d'électricité voilà c'est à dire donc
aux sites à dire qu'il ya des
entreprises qui ont des contrats qu'on
appelle les contrats interruptible des
contrats d'effacement avec acceptent de
ne pas consommer d'électricité à un
moment quand il ya des tensions sur
l'offre d'électricité et la production
d'accord donc ça c'est très probable ça
c'est très probable ça va aller ça peut
arriver comme ça ça peut arriver alors
la consommation d'électricité dépend de
la production industrielle est aussi de
la météo volant ménage donc à chaque
degré de froid supplémentaire on a
besoin de produire davantage donc là il
fait très chaud en ce moment sur toute
la france c'est pousser sa sas alors
effectivement le problème va se poser
plutôt l'hiver d'accord même si à la
climatisation en été et nokia joue aussi
et l'autre problème c'est que
l'électricité ne se stocke pas à la
différence des autres l'alliance du gaz
ou du pétrole c'est intéressant voilà
donc il faut un équilibre en temps réel
entre l'offre et la demande donc si tout
le monde consomme à un moment et qu'on
peut pas produire suffisamment il ya il
peut y avoir un problème de black out
c'est à dire de pénurie à un moment
instantané ça peut arriver ça voilà
alors que sur le gaz on a des stocks en
france qui représente 90 % qui sont
remplis à 90% mais les stocks gaziers ne
représentent que 25% de la consommation
de bière en gaz en gaz ça devrait aller
ou pas en bien ça devrait bien se passer
en électricité où il ya des rendez vous
est un gars en gaz pour les industriels
ça peut être tendu aussi parce que les
stocks ne représentent même s'ils sont
remplies presque à 100% que 25 % la
consommation de viande française alors
moi j'ai une question à vous poser est
ce qu'on va pas de ce qu'il est possible
qu'on demande aux ménages français à un
moment des revoilà de données de dire
voilà à partir d'une certaine heure plus
d'électricité alors c'est arrivé dans
les années soixante dix il ya eu un plan
après le choc pétrolier où on avait eu
des mesures qui ont été prises il ya le
japon après la catastrophe nucléaire de
fukushima
pareil cas mis en place un plan de
rationnement alors on parle de guerre
économique donc on dit qu'il faut être
en économie de guerre tout ça ça casse
beaucoup l'ambiance mais on va dire que
ça il faut une économie un peu de le
rationnement pour ceux qui le peuvent et
éviter le gaspillage énergétique cette
année et à l'avenir que ce soit à cause
de la crise énergétique ou % par rapport
au réchauffement climatique et pour
sauver la planète oui à arles due à un
mètre maire de nogent le rotrou ils nous
voient aujourd'hui je vous rappelle si
vous nous rejoignez parce que il a vu sa
piscine municipale fermée donc ça
commence vraiment voilà à chauffer vous
vouliez dire quelque chose je pense que
l' avantage de l'électricité c'est que
ça s'ajuste plus vite que le gaz c'est à
dire on ferme une piscine c'est
l'équivalent de la consommation de 1000
habitants d'accord on arrive à faire une
très grosse usine avec des compartiments
réfrigérés dans l'agroalimentaire on
arrête la production l'entreprise
continue d'écouler ses stocks ont fait
un mois de chômage pour les deux partiel
pour les salariés et là aussi on
récupère l'équivalent de 1000 1500
habitants donc c'est des choses qu'on a
qu'on sait organiser et sur lequel on
travaille avec les préfectures depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois